sehr geehrter herr bundespräsident
sehr geehrter herr bundeskanzler
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
wir trauern um herrn michael
sergejewitsch gorbatschow der am
dreißigsten august verstorben ist
präsident gorbatschow war ein mann des
friedens er veränderte die welt zum
besseren
er machte möglich was über jahrzehnte
undenkbar schien
den kalten krieg friedlich zu beenden
und die teilung unseres landes und
unseres kontinents zu überwinden
wir deutschen haben michael gorbatschow
viel zu verdanken
er hat die geschichte unseres landes und
das leben von millionen menschen
verändert
sein mut und seine haltung waren
entscheidend für die wiedererlangung
unserer staatlichen einheit diesen
einzigartigen und großen moment unserer
geschichte das werden wir nicht
vergessen
er war wegbereiter der wiedervereinigung
mit seinem unverhofften aufbruch in eine
neue politik hatte den menschen in der
ddr mut gemacht sich selbst zu
ermächtigen
glasnost und perestroika
warum sollte das nicht auch in der ddr
möglich sein
auch sein besuch in ost-berlin im
oktober 1909 180 zum vierzigsten starts
jubiläum der ddr trug dazu bei dass die
deutschen in der ddr gegen die
sed-diktatur aufbegehrten
als frauen und männer
1989 in immer größerer zahl in plauen in
leipzig in ostberlin in dresden in
schwerin in magdeburg und an vielen
anderen orten in der ddr auf die straße
ging fragten sich viele werden wieder
panzer rollen
doch die sowjetischen soldaten blieben
in ihren kasernen
das ende der ddr und die deutsche
wiedervereinigung
erfolgten friedlich
die us amerikanische publizistin
applebaum schrieb ich zitiere
gorbatschows radikalste handlung war der
verzicht auf gewalt zitat ende
gorbatschow versuchte letztlich nicht
das sowjet imperium mit militärischer
gewalt oder nuklearen drohungen zusammen
zu halten oder sich selbst mit gewalt
an die macht zu klammern
seine politik des erklärten gewalt zu
verzichten und seine aufgabe des
moskauer herrschaftsanspruchs gegen den
gegenüber den satelliten staaten stärken
die bürgerrechtsbewegung in mittel und
osteuropa seine entscheidung führten zur
freiheit für viele millionen menschen
michael gorbatschow selbst sagte dazu
1999 zehn jahre nach dem mauerfall hier
an diesem rednerpult und ich zitiere ihn
die tatsache dass die wiedervereinigung
gerade damals und gerade auf diese art
und weise stattgefunden hat ist ein
verdienst der völker
selbstzitat enden
die warschauer pakt staaten sollten
selbst über ihren weg entscheiden können
1989 und 1990 respektierte gorbatschow
ausdrücklich das selbstbestimmungsrecht
der völker
der kalte krieg ist zu ende verkündete
im dezember 1989 bei seinem treffen mit
us präsident george bush vor malta
bei seinem gipfeltreffen mit helmut kohl
in nordkaukasus im sommer 1990 stimmte
er auch der nato mitgliedschaft des
künftigen wiedervereinigten deutschlands
zu
am ende eines von zwei weltkriegen der
block konfrontation und der nuklearen
abschreckung geprägten jahrhunderts
erlebten wir einen friedlichen wandel
der auf mich oder
auch der für mich ehrlicherweise im
historischen rückblick ein ganz großes
glück war
insbesondere für unser land ein glück
für dass wir michael gorbatschow dankbar
bleiben werden
[Applaus]
mit seiner versöhnungsbereitschaft
leistete unschätzbares für die
historische aussöhnung zwischen
deutschen und russen die frage nach den
künftigen
deutsch-sowjetischen beziehungen
bewegten ihn wie auch 1990 immer wieder
an helmut kohl schrieb und auch wir in
deutschland haben uns eine
vertrauensvolle partnerschaft mit
russland gewünscht
ich sage mit großem bedauern dass eine
partnerschaft mit russland derzeit nicht
möglich ist
gorbatschow bezeichnete vertrauen als
den wichtigsten faktor in der
weltpolitik
mit vertrauen veränderte er die welt
sein vertrauen zu bundeskanzler kohl und
auch zu deutschland öffneten den weg zur
einheit unseres landes und für mich war
er einer der großen vertrauens stifter
des vergangenen jahrhunderts
dialog und vertrauen das war die
grundlage seines politischen handelns er
hatte den mut
eingefahrene wege zu verlassen die sich
als sackgasse erwiesen
er baute vertrauen auf zu es präsident
reagan und ersetzte vertrauen an die
stelle von abschreckung und
konfrontationen und das war eine
radikale kursänderung
dieses vertrauen wuchs auch als
gorbatschow von kompromissen sprachen
diese vokabel hatte man vorher selten
aus moskau gehört so brach er ausweglos
erscheinende konflikte auf
gorbatschow brachte neues denken in den
kreml er suchte die abkehr vom
gleichgewicht des nuklearen schreckens
mit dem ihren f vertrag über die
vernichtung der atomaren
mittelstreckenwaffen leute zu
gorbatschow und reagan
1987 das ende des nuklearen wettrüstens
zwischen den großmächten ein
mit der abrüstung wurde
weg zum friedlichen ende des kalten
krieges bereitet nach vier jahrzehnten
ost-west-konfrontation in europa
für seine abrüstungspolitik und für
seinen neuen weg in der außenpolitik
erhielt gorbatschow
1990 den friedensnobelpreis
als gorbatschow
1985 an der an die spitze der
sowjetunion aufstieg befand sich das
land bereits im niedergang
seine bürgerinnen und bürger lebten in
resignation
gorbatschow wollte mit reformen das
leben der sowjetbürger verbessern den
sozialismus weiterentwickeln ihm ein
menschliches antlitz geben er wollte die
angst in der beziehung zwischen dem volk
und der staatsführung ersetzen durch
dialog
auf einmal mischte sich dieser junge
staatsmann bei seiner ersten dienstreise
in das damalige leningrad unters volk er
fragte die menschen nach ihren sorgen
und problemen und er versprach
änderungen
seine offenheit und sein aktives werden
um die bevölkerung waren gar geradezu
unerhört hatte doch das volk in angst
vor der macht gelebt und die macht in
angst vor dem volk
glasnost und perestroika ging in die
internationale sprache ein
die neuen freiheiten wetten große
hoffnungen nun konnte man in der
sowjetunion freisprechen ohne haftbefehl
zu müssen sogar über die verbrechen des
stalinismus und den gulag wurde
gesprochen archive wurden geöffnet neue
zeitungen bücher erinnerungen erschienen
doch den niedergang
des kolonialen imperiums konnte
gorbatschow nicht mehr aufhalten
die sowjetunion war nicht mehr
reformierbar
gorbatschow der schritt für schritt
vorgehen wollte entglitt die kontrolle
über sein eigenes land im august 1991
wurde gegen ihn geputscht die völker der
sowjetunion strebt nach freiheit
und unabhängigkeit
am 25 dezember 1991 löste sich die
sowjetunion auf
es gibt wohl wenige politiker die in
deutschland so fair so viel verehrt
wurden wie er
und wir werden ihn als großen freiheits
geber in erinnerung behalten
die sehr unterschiedlichen reaktionen in
russland mittel und osteuropa und auch
in deutschland nach seinem tod zeigen
nicht nur die vielschichtigkeit seines
wirkens sie zeugen auch von
grundlegenden missverständnissen und der
tragik seines politischen lebens
er wurde einsam im eigenen land
in russland werden ihm der zerfall des
sowjetimperiums und die not der
neunzigerjahre angelastet er litt unter
dieser entfremdung von seinem eigenen
volk
im südkaukasus und im baltikum erinnert
man sich schmerzhaft an das brutale
vorgehen gegen friedliche
demonstrationen 1989 in tiflis
den schwarzen januar 1990 in
aserbaidschan und dem blutsonntag von
vilnius 1991 während seiner amtszeit
es fand später trotz aller bewunderung
und dankbarkeit auch eine gewisse
entfremdung mit dem westen statt
etwa in der bewertung der russischen
außenpolitik von putin
gorbatschow war vom westen durchaus auch
enttäuscht er machte sich aber dabei
nicht leicht er zog sich nicht zurück
sondern engagierte sich weiter
gorbatschows verdienste um das ende des
kalten krieges und die wiedervereinigung
unseres landes und unseres kontinents
bleiben einzigartig
die unterschiedlichen reaktionen zeigen
aber wie rainer feser in der faz
vergangene woche anmerkte welche
missverständnisse und enttäuschungen
seit jahren zwischen russland und dem
westen bestehen
gerade wir deutschen haben zu lange
gorbatschows streben nach verständigung
frieden und partnerschaft als grundlage
unserer beziehungen mit russland
vorausgesetzt dabei haben wir übersehen
oder vielleicht auch nicht wahrhaben
wollen dass sich russland unter putin
längst und radikal von gorbatschows
zielen abgewandt hatte
die entwicklung in seiner heimat
besorgte gorbatschow er rief die
regierenden in russland auf keine angst
vor den menschen zu haben und auch ihre
freiheit nicht zu unterdrücken
gleichzeitig setzte er vertrauen in die
russische zivilgesellschaft
besonders in die jungen menschen
russlands zukunft kann nur demokratie
bedeuten schrieb er 2009 10
gorbatschow war trotz aller rückschläge
und defizite zutiefst davon überzeugt
dass es letztlich kein zurück zur
totalitären vergangenheit geben er war
sich sicher dass nur eine demokratische
entwicklung seinem land eine zukunft
bieten kann
vor wenigen jahren sagte michael
gorbatschow in einem interview vom
interview wir wollten die mauern des
misstrauens zwischen ost und west
seitigen überhaupt jede mauer zwischen
staaten zwischen völkern zwischen
menschen zitat ende
zwischen russland und europa kraft heute
ein tiefer graben dort
wo nach gorbatschows vision ein
gemeinsames europäisches haus entstehen
sollte
mit russland und mit einer gemeinsamen
sicherheitsarchitektur
im juni 1990 schrieb er an helmut kohl
dass die überwindung des blogs systems
und die gestaltung neuer
sicherheitsstrukturen im
gesamteuropäischen geiste zu suchen sein
es ist russland das unter putin mit
diesem geist gebrochen hat und das ist
ein tragischer fehler
es ist russland das die ukraine angreift
und mit waffengewalt die europäische
friedensordnung zerstört
gorbatschow war ein mann des friedens
als kind hatte er den zweiten weltkrieg
erlebt und er wollte die welt von ihrer
größten bedrohung befreien immer wieder
mahnte er zur atomaren abrüstung und
warnte eindringlich vor der gefahr eines
neuen krieges
eine neuerliche konfrontation russlands
mit dem westen blieb bis zuletzt seine
größte sorge
michael gorbatschow stand für
gewaltverzicht für freiheit und für die
selbstbestimmung der völker er stand für
eine weltordnung in der staaten durch
dialog und auf grundlage des rechts
konflikte beilegen und gemeinsamen
lösungen für globale probleme suchen
es schmerzt uns zutiefst dass alles
wofür er stand heute auf so eklatante
weise verletzt und zerstört wird
gorbatschows mut kann uns aber auch in
diesen dunklen stunden
zuversicht vermitteln für die großen
herausforderungen vor denen wir jetzt
stehen er war humanist
er glaubte an die menschen und ihre
möglichkeiten
man kann wenn man will betonte er immer
wieder
selbst unter schwierigen bedingungen
lassen sich so meinte er neue lösungen
im interesse der welten gemeinschaft
finden man darf nicht aufgeben und sein
handeln war das beste beispiel dafür
[Applaus]
die welt muss nicht bleiben wie sie ist
auch nicht nach diesem brutalen krieg
den russland gegen die ukraine führt es
kann ein besseres morgen ein besseres
übermorgen geben aber der weg dahin wird
sicherlich lang und auch steinig wir
brauchen mutige menschen die für eine
friedliche gerechte und nachhaltige welt
bereit sind risiken einzugehen und
eingetretene pfade zu verlassen
die bereit sind neu zu denken und neu zu
handeln
politiker und persönlichkeiten wie
michael sergejewitsch gorbatschow
mit ihm verliert das deutsche volk einen
treuen freund
ich verneige mich vor dem großen welt
verändere und dem großartigen menschen
ich möchte sie jetzt bitten sich als
zeichen des respekts unserer dankbarkeit
und unserer trauer in gedenken an
michael gorbatschow von den plätzen zu
erheben für eine schweigeminute
ich danke ihm bitte nehmen sie wieder
platz
wir unterbrechen die sitzung jetzt und
werden um 39 mit der sitzung
fortfahren herzlichen dank
[Applaus]